it all started as a typical building job
bulldozers were working on the
construction of a residential project in
the jabalia neighborhood of Northeastern
Gaza but as construction workers dug to
lay the foundations they soon discovered
a piece of history that has astonished
archaeologists and
historians a Roman Cemetery believed to
be more than 2,000 years old although
not the first the historical context of
this finding makes it extremely
remarkable so far 134 Toms at least two
lead sarcophagy and pyramid shaped
burials have been
discovered the discovery of the lead
sarcophagy is a rare case of its kind
and a first in Gaza uh French
archaeologist Renee alter believes more
could still be found
this cemetery is a small part of the
entire archaeological Heritage of the
Gaza Strip you have to imagine that the
entire Gaza Strip at least along the
coast is a huge archaeological site
which means that today there is a real
danger as soon as there is a new
construction site we risk coming across
archaeological
Remains the presence of a Roman Cemetery
in Gaza indicates the once thriving
Commerce and cultural ties between this
region and the Roman Empire this
discovery is more than just an
archaeological achievement a window into
a world long gone and a Testament of the
ancient history of the Gaza Strip and
the people who lived
here F Al is a Palestinian archaeologist
who leads the excavation team it's a
project funded by the British government
and implemented by a global NGO but he
says the team is severely lacking in
resources and financial
assistance this presents a huge
Challenge from basic excavation gear to
proper preservation
facilities in Gaza we are facing great
difficulties due to the lack of
continued financial support for
archaeological discoveries because Gaza
is a rich historical City so this area
must be taken care of but the Israeli
occupation and lack of financial support
for archaeological excavations limit the
ease of access to
it this is Basha or the Pasha Palace
where all the artifacts and Tom findings
are being preserved and displayed but
Israel's yearslong blockade of Gaza
means not many Outsiders will get to see
it it also prevents International
archaeologists from exploring and
learning about its Rich history y alaz
Gaz make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer